en este vídeo vamos a hablar un poco
acerca de la membrana celular entonces
como un breve repaso digamos que esta es
una imagen de nuestra célula con un
núcleo pequeño en el medio nuestra
membrana celular es lo que está en el
exterior de esta célula por lo que
nuestra membrana celular es lo que
protege a la célula de un entorno
exterior hostil si no fuera por la
membrana celular hoy no estaríamos vivos
porque no habría nada que nos protegiera
del mundo exterior así que vamos a
hablar sobre las tres cosas principales
que componen la membrana celular la
primera los fosfolípidos la segunda el
colesterol y la tercera las proteínas el
primero del que hablaremos y esto
constituye la mayor parte de lo que hay
en nuestra membrana celular son los
fosfolípidos y para ahorrar tiempo he
dibujado una imagen de la membrana
celular aquí y notarán que todas estas
piezas individuales son fosfolípidos y
un fosfolípidos se ve así tiene una
cabeza de grupo polar este grupo polar
de fosfato y tiene dos colas de ácidos
grasos así es cómo representamos
normalmente el aspecto de un fosfolípido
y en la membrana celular
podemos ver que estos fosfolípidos están
muy juntos muy apretados en toda la
membrana estamos mirando esta membrana
en una sección transversal podemos
imaginar que cortamos la membrana por la
mitad entonces lo que tenemos aquí es en
realidad lo que llamamos nuestra bicapa
de fosfolípidos y a veces también se le
llama bicapa lipídica lo segundo que
podemos encontrar en nuestra membrana es
el colesterol ahora a menudo escuchamos
acerca del colesterol en los alimentos y
del colesterol en la sangre y creemos
que es algo malo pero en este caso el
colesterol es realmente muy importante
para nuestra membrana celular el
colesterol se ve así de nuevo por
cuestión de tiempo he dibujado
previamente como se ve notarán que el
colesterol tiene muchos anillos lo que
le da una estructura bastante estable y
lo que hace el colesterol es que se
inserta entre los fosfolípidos algo así
por lo que pienso en el colesterol como
un amortiguador mantiene la fluidez de
nuestras membranas celulares entonces a
medida que las temperaturas bajan el
colesterol ayudará a aumentar la fluidez
a medida que las temperaturas aumentan
el colesterol ayudará a reducir la
fluidez de la membrana celular por lo
tanto el colesterol mantiene nuestra
membrana celular en una especie de punto
medio feliz de fluidez y la tercera cosa
que componen nuestra membrana celular
son las proteínas y las proteínas son
realmente grandes dependiendo de la
célula algunas tendrán una cantidad
significativa de proteína en la membrana
y así las proteínas pueden tomar dos
formas principales la primera es que
puede ser una proteína que atraviesa
toda la membrana llamamos a esta una
proteína integral también podemos llamar
la proteína transmembrana y esto puede
ocurrir en diferentes áreas de la célula
así y algunas proteínas están asentadas
encima de la membrana de esta manera o
podrían ubicarse encima de otras
proteínas estas son las que llamamos
proteínas periféricas hay algunas
proteínas muy raras que en realidad
pueden atravesar la mitad de la membrana
y ocasionalmente hay algunas proteínas
aún más raras que se pueden encontrar
dentro de la membrana celular como está
entre los dos fosfolípidos dentro
esta bicapa ahora las proteínas tienen
un papel muy importante en la función de
las membranas celulares pues realizan
casi todos los procesos de la membrana
que podamos imaginar y las dos cosas más
importantes que hacen las proteínas son
en primer lugar actuar como receptores
las proteínas pueden decirle a la célula
lo que está sucediendo en el mundo
exterior actúan como comunicación y lo
segundo que pueden hacer las proteínas
que generalmente ocurre en las proteínas
transmembrana es que pueden ayudar a
transportar moléculas dentro y fuera de
la célula entonces ahora que conocemos
la función de las proteínas porque creen
que las proteínas que están unidas a
lípidos o unidas dentro de la bicapa
lipídica como está aquí son tan raras
bueno es porque si el papel de las
proteínas es principalmente actuar como
receptores comunicarse con el mundo
exterior o actuar como transporte para
permitir que las cosas vayan desde
adentro hacia afuera o desde afuera
hacia adentro las proteínas que están
atrapadas en el medio realmente no
tienen un papel importante en nuestra
membrana celular
y por último hay un tipo muy importante
de molécula que se une a nuestros
lípidos o nuestras proteínas y estos son
los carbohidratos llamamos a esto clico
para abreviar entonces serían
glicoproteínas o podrían ser glicol
hipidos y desempeñan un papel importante
en la comunicación por ejemplo permiten
que una célula reconozca a otra célula
en nuestro cuerpo si juegan un papel en
la comunicación en el reconocimiento
entre células donde creen que irían
estos azúcares bueno estos azúcares
estarían principalmente en el exterior
de nuestra membrana sobre saldrían de
las proteínas éstas serían
glicoproteínas y pueden estar en
proteínas periféricas o integrales o
pueden sobresalir de los lípidos como
éste y éstos serían clico lípidos ahora
es un poco confuso al verlo lo que
acabamos de dibujar es una sección
transversal de la membrana celular pero
qué pasaría si estuviéramos mirando la
membrana celular desde el exterior como
una vista superior cómo se vería eso
bueno nuevamente por cuestión de tiempo
he dibujado nuestros fosfolípidos y si
estuviéramos mirando la membrana
desde el exterior mirando la parte
superior todo lo que veríamos serían
estas cabezas de nuestros fosfolípidos
podríamos ver algo de colesterol entre
nuestras membranas celulares de esta
manera y podríamos ver algunas proteínas
más grandes que están en la parte
superior de nuestra membrana celular
como está dispersas por toda nuestra
célula y por último podríamos ver
algunas glicoproteínas iglic o lípidos
en el exterior y éstos se unirían a
nuestras proteínas y nuestros
fosfolípidos así entonces desde arriba
así es como se vería nuestra membrana
celular y sabemos algo realmente
especial sobre esto esto parece como una
obra de arte
entonces si pensamos en la escuela
primaria en el proyecto donde juntábamos
muchos frijoles o macarrones diferentes
para crear una obra de arte esto
recuerda eso esto es en realidad lo que
llamamos un mosaico los científicos
pensaron lo mismo y ellos llamaron a
este modelo de la membrana celular el
modelo de mosaico fluido y así la
porción de mosaico de nuestra célula se
puede describir aquí una vez más pueden
ver que hay muchas piezas
y diferentes tipos de elementos
coloridos que juntos crean esta hermosa
membrana celular pero por qué lo
llamamos fluido bueno la razón por la
que llamamos fluida a la membrana
celular es porque estas piezas en la
membrana celular pueden moverse no están
fijas las proteínas y los fosfolípidos
en la membrana celular pueden moverse
así por eso la llamamos fluida cómo
sería eso si miramos la membrana celular
desde la parte superior bueno
el movimiento en realidad no es
bidimensional solo arriba y abajo o solo
izquierda y derecha en realidad pueden
ir en muchas direcciones diferentes
nuestras proteínas pueden moverse por
toda la membrana celular y también
nuestros fosfolípidos de nuevo esto es
lo que llamamos el modelo de mosaico
fluido y un hecho curioso es que esto se
descubrió apenas en 1972 por lo que fue
hace solo 40 años que descubrimos que
nuestra membrana celular era en realidad
el modelo de mosaico fluido en resumen
la membrana celular se compone de tres
cosas principales lo primero son los
fosfolípidos éstos constituyen la mayor
parte de la
celular y son un elemento básico para
que exista lo segundo es el colesterol
el colesterol se dispersa aleatoriamente
a través de la membrana celular y ayuda
a mantener la fluidez de la misma y el
tercero son las proteínas que llevan a
cabo casi todas las funciones esenciales
de la membrana celular